my mom has been super open and accepting
to me eating a plant-based diet she has
helped me veganize a ton of recipes and
she's taught me everything i know about
cooking hi i'm rachel and this is my mom
hi i'm carla and we're gonna host a
vegan thanksgiving this will be my
fourth thanksgiving that i've been vegan
and while my family still makes a turkey
we veganize all of the sides so like the
green bean casserole we use non-dairy
milk the stuffing is vegan we just use
like vegan butter in the mashed potatoes
and my dad and my brother don't even
notice it's been really easy and great
one of the concerns i had when we
decided to veganize the thanksgiving
dinner was that we would lose our
traditions and i have found that i don't
miss certain things and we are starting
new traditions i used to always make the
gizzards with my dad on thanksgiving and
we'd have that as like a little pre
thanksgiving snack while watching the
parade but then i started to find that
we just replaced these traditions with
new ones so now my dad and i will have a
different special beer every year and
try something new i think what we also
realize is that it's really about being
together and enjoying a meal as opposed
to the individual foods i try to eat
plant-based but i can't say i do it 100
at all when i go in the grocery store i
almost never buy meat because i feel you
on my shoulder disapproving
some of the things that i realized that
i cook are already vegan and i had never
thought of it for example when i was
growing up grandma would always make
like pasta brazil which is peas and
onions and pasta sometimes i have a
recipe with broccoli rob and cannellini
beans a lemon so there are a lot of
things that you might enjoy that are
already vegan you don't have to go crazy
thinking about looking for something new
that's vegan
so this thanksgiving we're going to have
a mushroom wellington this is a
delicious recipe that rachel brought
into our lives and i've given it to
people i work with who love it and it's
just it's just great first of all we all
love mushrooms in my family so you layer
mushrooms and potatoes and spinach and
wrap it in a puff pastry and it's just
really really good and it looks very
beautiful and elegant so it makes a
really nice presentation so i think that
desserts are one of the easiest things
to make vegan i've made a few videos in
the past i've made vegan chocolate chip
cookies and vegan fudgy brownies and i
just don't think that anyone would eat
that and know that it's vegan or think
it doesn't taste good i think they taste
exactly the same
so i saw a recipe online for a vegan
pumpkin cheesecake so i thought that'd
be a fun recipe to try out with my mom
and this cheesecake came out awesome i
was so impressed by the texture and the
creaminess of it and i know that i've
been vegan for a few years now but the
one thing that i definitely do not miss
is dairy because it's just so easy to
replicate the texture the creaminess
with things like coconut milk silken
tofu cashews it's just something that i
think a lot of people would really love
if they tried and i just think that
making little changes like this without
taking away from the food are so
important because they have such a big
impact on the environment and on our
health and on animal welfare and can
really add up and make a big difference
when rachel cooks vegan for me i'm
thrilled her cooking is so delicious
and i've often said to her that if she
moved home i would be 100 vegan she
cooked for me every day and she also
enjoys feeding people i see that when i
watch her and i was always the same way
and so was my mother so you do get
pleasure when you give food to people
and you see them enjoy it
now let's try this cheesecake
that's the stuff
very good
[Music]
[Music]
you